I ran across this cool shawl,
and I love the simplicity of the lace.
And I immediately thought,
"we can knit this on the machine."
Yes, the original is in garter stitch.
There are no purl stitches,
hence the name.
But by knitting it on the machine,
we can have the best of both worlds
with different texture on both sides.
But bells started going off in my head
about biasing when transferring eyelets
in the same direction every time.
Here's the stitch pattern. Create an eyelet,
every other needle, every other row.
I started to work the transfers
manually
on my mid-gauge machine.
Starting on the left,
I transferred, knit
across then knit a row.
Then transferred again knit across, knit a row.
But those little bells were right.
I could quickly see that by transferring
in the same direction every
time, the knitting was biasing.
Even though technically it's biasing,
the stitch pattern is really pretty
and could be a beautiful scarf
or cowl with a diagonal design.
An automatic patterning machine would
make really quick work of this.
But to prevent the bias,
I alternated the transfers.
Starting by working left to right,
I transferred my eyelets
to every other needle.
Knit across and knit back.
Then I transferred in the other
direction from right to left.
This straightened out the knitting
and makes a simple, beautiful,
open work lace that we could
use for this Purl Thief Shawl.
By the way, if you don't like triangular
shawls, borrow the ideas from this design
and use the Knit it Now
tool and make it a rectangle.
You're the designer.